yeah the happiest people i knew in
university were the guys who couldn't be
bothered today i remember because i used
to i used to be an r.a so i used to
manage a thousand students um and it's
why i learned a lot of this stuff
because people talk about the stuff they
think i'm manipulative no i just know
women in it i've actually been out here
for like for like years in it um and one
of the guys he's like i think he's like
um an actuary and his friend
two of the happiest human beings i've
ever met i walked in there
just chilling making lunch for each
other they used to go gym do all this
stuff but i never heard them discuss
women they weren't dating anyone they
didn't give a flying [ __ ] he still
hasn't purchased anything happy people
the people i know who sleep around men
as well because hypergamy does make a
lot of men unhappy are you know they're
constantly in that drama phase they're
constantly like yeah great it's not it's
not a happy place which is why everyone
should have a roster
or spin places same thing
sorry isn't the roster the same thing
but as in
shallow relationships with multiple
people so you're just running through
them as i said i don't run through
people like like the rush they are
actually valid people i just don't want
to settle down so why would i build a
really intense relationship with one
person but see that's you i think and
there may be obviously a percentage of
men that do that and that's that's fine
but you also have other percentage of
men like if we broke it down to a pie
chart you have the men that out here
just having sex for ego and just to be
validated
you have the men that are doing it
because they don't want a relationship
but they want some company and that's
fine they're not really trying to hurt
anyone out here but they're not trying
to set it down cool then you have the
men that actually want to get married
have like an actual life with a woman
then you have the men that are actually
damaged because they've been they've
been women that are damaged now they
have damage and they don't end up
getting with anyone because they're no
they get the most girls actually the
damage but you know what happens with
them
the 34 year olds the 50 year olds the
six girls that stay single but have to
keep dating young girls because older
women
she don't want you no actually it's
easier to get older
i think no i'm saying he'll date younger
women because the old woman at certain
point an older woman she'll either
settle
or she'll be like i can't be bothered to
put up with this there's two types of
women they'll settle they won't
put up with what put up with someone who
for example is too stubborn doesn't care
about their feelings don't want to give
them attention well that just means
she's shooting out of her league if like
that's the way the guy treats you she
doesn't like you
you're just i'm saying
that toxic place after they've not
transitioned like she'll put up if it's
high value
there's different types of women i'm
just talking about different types of
men and i'm saying that's fine because
you're in a different place but i'm
saying if we're looking at percentages
of men in general you have these
different types of men just like how you
have these different types of women like
there's no general for anyone let's be
honest you know why like those damaged
men do the best in the dating market
yeah because they know how to play the
game because they're good at flipping
between alpha and beta they're not good
at being like the tough guy but they
also have deep emotional needs so
they'll try and connect with these women
emotionally they'll flip between them
they're not like you though you're
saying that you don't connect with them
on that level because you understand
your emotional like say boundaries to
keep yourself away from that because you
don't want that but some men
they might be like oh yeah i want this
actually freak out it's the same with
women that's what i'm saying like the
pie chart is there if if a woman's
freaking out in the courting stage
you're doing something wrong you're
going wait because every single woman i
date generally if they're good
intelligent women most women want a
long-term relationship if they're not
with you then you're missing something
and you know you're probably giving way
too much attention validation you're
probably needy there's something there
because the longer you spend with a
woman the more she's gonna like you in
it women are like that when she's
committed to spending time with you
she's not
i'm not speaking for america you guys
are crazy i don't know what's going on
over there
i'm just saying i'm sorry what are you
talking about london
london is not better no
a mini america yeah yeah i forgot i
forget i'm in london sometimes because
it's so americanized we're way behind
we're 10 years behind you guys i think
we're getting there but
i see videos of women being like oh i do
this and i leave i like i sleep with men
and i ghost them i was like what
i mean you've seen some of the vlog the
blog pages here you guys got wild [ __ ]
on those too
i haven't seen that
but yeah so they're good at flipping
with that but um but that's the
transition period there's a transitional
period in life
sorry in other words they've got game
yeah but there's the transition
because it's kind of pathetic these guys
also i i'm going to settle this once and
for all right this idea that sleeping
with loads of women means you're like a
top guy it doesn't it just means exactly
most of the time it means you're a loser
it means you don't you don't have any
goals why do you need an ego stroke
you're not you're not pushing for
anything you have way too much time to
spend you know
putting like 20 women in the talking
stage and then dealing with all their
games until you fight they finally sleep
with you it normally means high value
men are selective not just anyone can
walk into my life
exactly usually usually they are making
up for an insecurity or they're trying
to feed the ego normally they spent too
much time in a long-term relationship in
like their early twenties and then she
left and then they're trying to make up
now they want to date all that but
they've got also debatable they're
getting a lot of attention now that's
normally what i see the guys who are
sleeping with being promiscuous past
like 25 to like in their 40s they dated
one girl for like seven years when they
were like 18 and then she left and then
they think [ __ ] i could have slept with
all these hotties and now now they just
want to stick with as many as possible
that's why they say that like men with
more sexual partners are like happier in
their relationships you cannot just say
exactly what you just said so men so
when men
okay the happiest relationships are when
like they're both virgins like that's
number one
but it's like if a man slept with around
i don't remember exactly what it was but
it was roughly like three partners
versus eight or nine partners he's
happily he's happier in his relationship
when he said eight or nine yeah i i
attested that i think
men this has just been my experience the
more women i've slept with the more i've
worked out what it is i want what i
don't want it's essentially it's
unintentionally been a screening process
or weeding out the weak type of process
and now it's me and now it's essentially
it left me in a position where i knew
exactly what i wanted what was
completely non-negotiable
and
i would shoot for that i would be very
selective and that's made me very happy
now you have to screen guys like there's
no a lot of guys are frustrated right
now and you know i see it in the
comments because a lot of guys you give
way too much time and attention to women
who have nothing to offer back and they
get frustrated and as a guy who's been
way past that stage i'll tell you most
of these people aren't they don't care
about you they don't like you the
average woman so you've got a screen too
oh yeah a lot of guys looked at that
that stage and were like you know like i
think i just talked to anyone on the
road nah b i have to kind of lack and
respect you first like that's just a
stage and the ignoring bit is
when i have conversations i say things
and try and inquire but if someone
doesn't give me a good enough response
if it's not like if i ask her more than
three questions and she doesn't ask me
anything back i just stopped replying
right like i'll just read you know i
i have a super chat real quick it says
people wanting real solutions this is a
conversation about healing seeing
acupuncturist or a tantric yoga expert
so on the damage is not permanent
there's no perfect solution but if you
don't mind it don't matter commit to
what matters okay go ahead kid i have a
question for the fellas do you think
that the more sexual partners a guy has
been with the harder it is for him to
accept one woman for the rest of his
life no
no no no
i think well actually i don't want to
generalize here i'm going to say
specifically for my for my position no i
think getting loads out of my system
when i was younger has allowed me to be
far more selective know what i want and
what i don't want as and now has
made me very specific in who i want to
go for and as
i i am now in a happy long-term
relationship as a result and i attribute
a lot of that to essentially the
quote-unquote weeding out process that i
went to i think
so the host can kind of be like
can i ask you a question yeah you you
helped pave the way for the [ __ ]
woman in the future as many of you know
i was just banned on tick tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible